The solution to the system is 3, 2. We want to start by solving for one of the
variables and one of the equations. I think it's easiest to solve for y in this
equation. You can also solve for x or y in this equation and still wind up with
the same result. I can take the equation, subtract 3x from both sides, to get
negative y equals negative 3x plus 7. Remember these are not like terms, so I
just list them. Now I need the positive y value, so I divide every term by
negative 1. We could also think about multiplying every term by negative 1, so y
equals 3x minus 7. Now we can perform substitution, we can take 3x minus 7 and
substitute it in for y. Since that's what it equals. Here I've replaced y with
3x minus 7, then I distribute the 2, distributing the 2, I get 2x plus 6x minus
14 equals 10. I combine my terms so 8x minus 14 equals 10. Then I add 14 to both
sides, so 8x is 24 and finally we divide both sides by 8, so x is equal to 3. So
we found x, but remember we still need to find y. I can use this first equation
to find y, since it's already solved for. I replace x with the value of 3, so y
equals 3 times 3 minus 7, or 9 minus 7, which is 2. And remember, you can always
make sure that you're right. Check the answer 3, 2 by plugging it into both
equations. Do you come out with true statements? If so, you did great.